were you were you guys watching the
prelims like there was this long like
Ronda Rousey like promo and you're like
why why is this taking on so long
because Jake and Jay Heron were filming
for the movie and they didn't want you
to see that but the you know on online
the crowd's like what's going on they're
filming it ah it shows him like it shows
Jake Gyllenhaal again against cage gets
hit then he gets then he hits uh Jay
here on and he throws a jumping knee
yeah yeah there it is I mean I'm not
sure we could show this so anyways
there's you can go on any like website
there's you'll see Jake Gyllenhall and
Jay here on fake fighting that's cool
that they have Jay here I mean J huron's
doing all these movies now because he
was you know using UFC for a while but
then he's the band yeah he's been doing
movies for a while